[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANTOS: I'm Adele Santos, Dean
of the School of architecture
and Planning here
at MIT, and it's
my pleasure to welcome
you all on this hideous
evening, actually.
It's great that so
many of you came,
and I want to thank Mark
[INAUDIBLE] who is, I think,
here, and Darian [INAUDIBLE],,
wherever he is sitting.
There you go, Darian.
For doing this, actually.
For coming with the idea, for
doing the research [INAUDIBLE]
and making this event happen.
We're very proud that
[INAUDIBLE] at our school.
Just a few words about
MIT and the kinds
of issues that are going
to be discussed today.
MIT takes on-- when
problems are presented,
it often takes on the
issues with great speed
and helpfulness
[INAUDIBLE] for example.
It went out of its way to
deal with issues of equity,
and I think from
that period onward,
the whole issue of increasing
diversity on our campus
has been something that's
constantly discussed.
It may seem that
we are rarefied,
but the truth is we've looked
at the numbers of students
from all over the
world, from all sorts
of different ethnicities
increasing by year.
It's improving from the number
of black students and Latino
students.
We've also been making
an equitably large effort
to try and bring in a
more diverse faculty.
The truth is we do bring
in quite large numbers
of black faculty
in some disciplines
but we do a lousy job of somehow
keeping them, and getting them
through the process to
tenure, and this is something
we're very acutely aware of.
I've been here for
three years now,
and we have somebody sitting
on academic council that
meets every week who
actually is in charge of some
of these issues,
particularly when
we say under represented
minorities, which really,
includes women still
today, although I think
the issues that have been
problematic for women have been
on the process of being solved.
We, in our school,
also have a committee
that deals with issues of
diversity of which Mark
has been a lead player
for quite a time,
and we are the first school
at MIT to have hired somebody
who's full-time job is to
be the manager of diversity
recruitment.
And where are you?
Could you please stand up?
This is Robin Chatwin, who is--
[APPLAUSE]
Robin is charged with
helping us get the best
database we can in the world.
She's here to work with
our diversity committee.
the student committees,
and I felt that if we
went on talking about it,
and didn't actually have
someway to be looked
after on a day to day basis,
we weren't doing as good a job
as we can.
So Robin, we were very
fortunate to find her.
She's got her PhD from MIT,
and EECS by the media lab.
So she knew MIT.
She knew our culture, and
bless her, she put up her hand,
and said I'd like to do
this, and here she is.
And I've heard you'll have
a chance to speak with her,
and I'm sure she'll be asking
your help in all sorts of ways.
So that's Robin.
So I would like to now turn
to welcoming Ellen Weiss, who
received her PhD from the
University of Illinois Urbana
Champagne.
And she's now a professor
of architectural history
today at the University, and
somehow survived the flood,
and is there actively trying
to keep the school together
[INAUDIBLE].
She has received many
awards for her work,
and she studies the history of
African American architects.
One of the people
she focuses in on
is Robert R. Taylor, who
graduated from MIT very early
on.
He was the first black
architect to graduate
from this degree
in architecture,
who went on then to
have a glorious career,
and was very influential in
the building of [INAUDIBLE]..
So we thought it was appropriate
to start with you, Ellen.
And the drawings,
as you probably all
realize now are
from Taylor's thesis
we have in our collection, and
it's outside the [INAUDIBLE]
really quite interesting.
So with that introduction,
welcome, and thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
WEISS: Dean Santos, the
news is better than that.
Robert Taylor is MIT's
first black graduate,
not just the school
of architecture,
and he's also the first
professional trained
African-American
architect, and was
the first who was trained in
the school [INAUDIBLE] when
I was trained.
I think that's very significant,
and quite wonderful.
I'm very grateful to MIT
for inviting me here.
I want very, very much
for MIT to realize
the historical gem you have.
[AUDIO OUT]
Robert Taylor was the
first academically trained
African-American architect,
and MIT's first black graduate,
class of 1892.
He spent his career as a
teacher, administrator,
and designer of Booker T.
Washington's Tuskegee Normal
and Industrial Institute, a
residential vocational high
school in east central Alabama.
He designed around 40 brick
buildings there, and elsewhere,
plus some unknown
number of wooden ones.
It was Taylor's good fortune--
I completely forgot
they come with slides.
It's my responsibility.
Is it on?
Yes, there we go.
There he is.
There he is in 1906.
It was Taylor's
good fortune to be
born in Wilmington,
North Carolina, which
was a prosperous port town
with, before the civil war,
many, many excellent black
builders, and some builder
architects, both slave and free.
During Reconstruction,
Wilmington even
had black residents
on the city council.
It was ideally close to
being something approaching
an integrated city, except of
course, as many of you know,
it all erupted and
reversed in 1898
with the so-called
Wilmington Massacre,
but we're not going there.
Taylor wasn't
there at that time.
Robert Taylor's father was a
literate [INAUDIBLE] slave,
who's own--
technically save-- who's own
white father and master allowed
him the personal
freedom so that he
could prosper as a merchant,
carpenter, and contractor.
This is the Taylor
family home, which
was built by his
father, Henry Taylor,
only now we have the
little [AUDIO OUT]
Robert Taylor standing on the
right in the final photographs.
He's always on the
edge of the group,
and I wanted to linger
on this to point out
the little boy there
was Taylor's son.
But instead, he worked as a
builder for a year or two,
and then went north to MIT.
Taylor's MIT years
were a success,
as Clarence Williams has shown.
He was at or near
the top of his class,
and awarded a scholarship
for the second two
years of his four-year course.
While Taylor's
architecture appears
[INAUDIBLE] in course four,
were distinctly Yankee,
his larger institute class
would have been international.
A description of the
class of the previous year
put it this way,
raised at the edge.
67% were white complexioned,
33% dark, 11% wore eye glasses,
and one was color blind, and
50% thought they had mustaches.
Taylor clearly belonged in the
later 50% as well as the 33%.
The academic schedule
was demanding,
with too many courses
by modern standards,
and such particular
architecture course for horrors
is called [INAUDIBLE]
drawings [INAUDIBLE]
done on the blackboard to
then unspecified scale.
Course four had an
art based pedagogy,
with history
lectures with paired
slides, weekly supervised trips
to the Museum of Fine Arts,
prestigious research
in the library,
monthly designed problems,
and juried reviews.
As one student wag put it,
where is an all well-conducted
abattoirs, the customs is to
slaughter before rendering,
the process here is
reversed, and all work
is rendered first, and
slaughtered afterwords.
Taylor also learned from
MIT's own construction, namely
the purpose designed
architecture building
that was up the after he left.
Pearce building was the six
story, industrial structure
with a stone and
brick mason facade
that freely mixes classical,
medieval, and industrial
elements in ways that suggest--
I think suggests aspects of
what Taylor would eventually
imply at Tuskegee.
Taylor's final thesis.
An ideal to own during
the lifetime of practice
was a home for
civil war veterans
from both North and South.
I need to interject a little
bit parenthetically right here.
Taylor is not MIT's only
contribution to MIT,
an engineering student
named Harry B. Taylor
didn't graduate,
but was probably
around at about this time,
arrived at Tuskegee shortly
after Taylor did, and stayed
there for his entire career.
This is something
that [INAUDIBLE]
students can take on.
Taylor was corresponding with
Booker T. Washington somewhere
after graduation.
While he was a, quote,
building mechanic
at a hotel on Martha's
Vineyard, Washington
was recruiting university
educated African-Americans
for Tuskegee.
He also wanted a black architect
to design the expanding campus,
and to prove the race's
ability to a watching world.
Washington with seeing
the young Richard Morris
Hunts, three large buildings
go up at the Hampton Institute.
Architects, Washington
learned, can best
articulate an
institution's purposes.
Taylor then went to Cleavland
to begin a practice,
but soon accepted
Washington's lure, arriving
at Tuskegee in November 1892.
His first Alabama completion was
the frame industry's building,
and another school,
and he probably
also drew the cottage
plans and elevations
that Washington
gave out to farmers
who attended the institute's
self-help conferences.
Tuskegee was always
about outreach.
It's mission, a vast
rural hinterland
with hundreds of
thousands of very, very
poor, usually landless farmers,
sharecroppers, tend farmers.
Brick buildings
at Tuskegee began
with-- it was first
called science, and then
Thrasher Hall, and
then the chapel.
Inside the chapel,
I particularly
liked this photograph.
It's very hard to get
photographs inside the chapel,
but these are not students.
These are the farmers.
This is a farmers
conference, and when
you think about how these people
from the dregs of the bottom
of society were
invited into what
would be the vastest
building they probably
could ever enter in their
lives, and the building
was electrically it.
It was the first electrically
building in the county.
I think that we begin to
understand the meaning
and the significance of this
young [INAUDIBLE] architect
makes it a [INAUDIBLE].
Chapel.
The Oaks, which is Booker T.
Washington's home, Boys Trades
Building, and Huntington Home.
There would have
also been innumerable
wooden cottages, barns, rural
schools, and other service
structures.
Teaching, however, was
Taylor's heaviest task.
There he is at the edge.
Since students had to draw
everything they were to make,
every trade-- steam filling,
plumbing, shoe making, tin
smithing, tailoring,
carriage building,
wheel routing started
with plans and elevations
because drawing promoted
modern industrial processes,
and was thought, consequently,
genuine intellectual growth.
Drawing had a racial dimension
because it taught planning,
or as they thought, turned
the executive thinking
that slave artisans, who
supposedly worked only
under strict supervision,
were thought to have lacked.
Taylor also developed
advanced drawing courses
for the building trades, and a
pre-professional post-graduate
architectural certificate
that he awarded
to [INAUDIBLE] major, the
future architect, William Sydney
Pittman.
Tuskegee's army of
drawing students
probably overwhelmed
the teacher,
contributing to
his 1899 decision
to return to Cleavland.
It took two instructors
to replace him.
In Cleveland, Taylor worked
for a white architect
with some Rockefeller
commissions,
and then on his own, but he
kept Tuskegee as a client.
From Cleveland, he did the
Girls Industries building,
and here it is more
recently, but not now,
which was called Dorothy Hall.
The Lincoln Gates, and
that's actually Dorothy Hall
and the chapel behind it.
In fact, they all have the
same donors-- the [INAUDIBLE]
step-sisters of New York who
gave the gates, and Dorothy
Hall, and the Chapel.
The boys and girls
the bath houses.
Here's the boys bath house.
When you work on a
project too long,
and you find that it's lucky you
have a shot of it because it's
since been demolished,
and Huntington Memorial
Academic building,
which I'm going
to show you in color because
tragically, that too was gone.
It burned.
Taylor returned to Tuskegee
around 1902, but now
as Director of Boy's Industries.
He headed 20 to 30
trades divisions,
each with its own shop,
classroom, and faculty.
As an academic
administrator, he was
responsible for
hundreds of students
who were enrolled in a
complicated curriculum that
interlocked with the
academic program,
and with much
greater difficulty,
with income-generating
industrial production.
Tuskegee depended on such
commercial enterprises
as printing
implemented [INAUDIBLE]
or brick making for income
and in Washington's theory,
to win intolerance.
We know now, of course, how
tragic such hopes turned sour
elsewhere, but Washington
and his successors
actually made it work
for Macon County.
Tuskegee remained an oasis
of safety when other places
weren't.
Tuskegee also projected
a quasi-Utopian image
to the northern
philanthropists that it
was supporting because it fed,
clothed, and sheltered itself
with its own skilled hands,
while preparing the students
to go out, and do
the same for others.
Because Tuskegee constructed
its own buildings,
it also failed to tailor to
coordinate simultaneous jobs
among the various shops, seeing
to it that material, foramen,
and student workers
were smoothly deployed,
and the buildings came in
on time, and within budget.
He was also responsible
for campus infrastructure,
the endless drainage and
sanitation problems, power
and water supply,
walkways and roads,
and the minutia of individual
office and classroom needs--
hanging a picture,
or cutting a doorway,
or getting the graffiti
washed out of a bathroom.
It is hard to
imagine how he did it
all while simultaneously
running all
of the industrial
divisions, and after hours,
designing buildings.
He seems to have credited
his education for his ability
to juggle multiple
tasks, but he also
rested by reading,
nurturing a special fondness
for Shakespeare.
Taylor's architecture from 1901
until 1915, when Washington
died, included still
more brick buildings,
such as the Carnegie
Library, which is still alive
and well, at least
on the outside,
not the inside, Rockefeller
Hall, the four Emory
dormitories, the office
building, Douglas Hall--
that's an entrance
into an auditorium.
He started taking advantage
of the slope, the arched part
and the low part.
Tantum Hall-- whoops.
Douglas Hall, White Hall.
This is White Hall.
Tantum Hall.
I skipped Andrew Hospital
for various reasons,
but there is a hospital in here.
The veterinary hospital.
The veterinary hospital,
and the new laundry.
He also designed
Carnegie Library
for Wiley University in
Marshall, Texas, and Livingston
college is my favorite,
so I put it last.
Livingston college in
Salisbury, North Carolina.
He did not design
the largest building
of the period,
Tompkins Dining Hall,
and you're seeing
it from the rear,
so you can see how big
a complex this one is.
Perhaps-- and this
is my speculation--
perhaps, because
he did not trust
himself to work at a scale
that demanded steel framing.
A white experienced
courthouse did it,
but our guy represented
the Institute
and the architect to each other,
shaped Washington's programming
and planning decisions,
argued the project
before the trustees, and after
the white guy's untimely death
with construction,
figured out how to set
the dome on wood trusses--
kind of see that
there's a dome--
dome on wood trusses without
having posts interrupt
the dining room's spacial
unity that Washington
very badly wanted.
Taylor's buildings revealed
his MIT-trained Bozart roots,
even when there are no obvious
classical elements on display,
as there are in the new Laundry.
They are characterized
by triadic masons--
this is what you're
supposed to see here--
with emphasized centers
that are embraced
by flanking units that lend a
strong sense of horizontality
to the mass.
They have finely
tuned proportions,
syncopated arrangements of
window shapes and sizes.
This is the stair
hall being picked out
from the back of a dormitory.
This is a case where there's
a real skin flint donor.
I think I have the front of it.
Taylor wanted a
two-story broader veranda
that would have more Palladian
impacts, centralizing impact,
and the donor was too
cheap to allow it.
So Taylor-- let's
see if we can reverse
it-- got his jollies by
doing the back like that.
Didn't cost a
cent, I would hope.
Occasional bursts of wit--
[INAUDIBLE] out of order here.
Those are the
syncopated windows.
Occasional bursts of wit,
hence the rhythmic play
on the second level.
There's nothing that
really demands that,
but I think the rhythm
of the entire facade,
and we can't see
the entire facade,
suggests that somebody very
clever is doing marvelous
stuff with minimal means.
And contrasts between sharp-cut
window voids, and the wall
planes that display
Tuskegee's richly
textured homemade bricks.
Tuskegee's bricks
are almost a kind
of icon of the
institution, and I'll
try not to go on
and on about that.
Just leave it up there.
Governor Washington talks
about when you get discouraged,
think about the
first brick making.
We almost failed,
but we carried on,
and we could build our school.
A few structures do break
into the formal rhetoric
of projecting homes under
entablatures and pediments.
Latin and Greek in
the words Washington
would use when you want to
put down what he considered
useless pretentiousness.
Washington once
told the students
that John D. Rockefeller,
who had given Tuskegee
a plain but elegantly
proportioned dormitory--
this is not it.
I'm a little bit messed up here.
Who had given a plain--
just leave it on this.
A plain, but
elegantly proportioned
dormitory, always used words of
one syllable, rather than two,
or two rather than three.
Rockefeller used no
Latin or Greek quotes,
and he was the richest
man in the world.
Full-blown classicism of early
20th century negro buildings
also raises thorny
critical questions.
The classical portico on
Tuskegee's Carnegie library--
and this is what we
want now, and here's
Tuskegee's Carnegie Library--
appeared the same year that
the new Alabama Constitution
stripped most black
people of the vote.
Whites were using
classical imagery
on similar institutions,
including courthouses
at the same time that this was
built, and at the same time
they were sanctioning violence
to enforce the increasing Jim
Crow restrictions running
through the South.
During the 1920s,
Taylor partnered
with a younger Carnegie-trained
black architect, Leo Persley,
on still more
Tuskegee buildings.
The [INAUDIBLE] Children's
House was the center of it
right there.
Sage hall, James Hall, and
the quad for the new college
department with a larger science
building, and a new library
building.
Here, much larger
facilities, and more
normative, and perhaps,
less interesting to us.
You have to get into
at least some of them.
This is Logan Hall, which
actually combines a gym
and an auditorium in one
space with a stage at the end,
and underneath the stage
is as swimming pool.
This became a neighborhood
cultural center with first run
movies, and famous musicians
who would travel through.
The white town, white
Tuskegee, could definitely
afford anything like this.
Tuskegee was really triumphing
over the town itself.
Taylor personally also
did substantial structures
elsewhere.
This is at Selma University in
Selma, and I can't show you--
and it's just as well
because it really
is pretty awesome--
a 64,000 square-foot,
seven-story colored Masonic
temple cum office building that
was also the social center
of Birmingham's black elite
through the age of segregation.
Important building.
I don't have a decent
photograph of it.
Most Taylor and
Persley buildings
were contracted to the
black-owned Wyndham brothers
firm in Birmingham, a company
in which Taylor was invested.
Taylor seems to have had
inherited his father's business
acumen, and had
many investments,
and little businesses on the
side, about which I wish I
knew more.
He's had five children
through college.
Throughout his life, Taylor's
personal reticence and tact
served the cause of
interracial diplomacy.
He traveled often to New York
to meet with trustees or donors.
In 1923, he was the ranking
administrator on campus
when the Ku Klux
Klan paraded through.
The clan was trying to
intimidate the Institute
into accepting white
medical staffing
for the adjacent
Veterans Administration
hospital for black patients.
Taylor stared the clan down,
while Tuskegee's principal,
Robert Russa Moton
and the NAACP were
negotiating the issue in
Washington D.C. Tuskegee won.
Taylor helped investigate
the refugee camps
for African-Americans displaced
by the 1927 Mississippi River
flood, concluding those in which
blacks shared in the management
were far better than those
in which they did not.
His diplomatic skills joined his
educational vision and design
talents in 1929 when
he traveled to Liberia
to help found the Booker
Washington Institute.
Taylor analyzed Liberia's
agricultural and industrial
potential, outlined a
curriculum to support it,
advised on governments
and staffing,
sketched a campus plan, and
designed a few buildings.
He then capped the
trip and his career
with a grand tour of Europe.
In 1932, the 64-year-old-- and
I don't know that he's 64 there,
but just deal with it.
The 64-year-old Robert R.
Taylor suffered a massive heart
attack.
He was visiting
his son in Chicago.
He retired shortly thereafter,
returning to Wilmington
so he would not
embarrass his successor.
There, he lived a gentleman's
life with a townhouse.
I don't know that he did it.
I think, probably,
he did not, but we
need to learn about that one.
With a townhouse and a waterside
retreat about 20 miles away.
He had a car and a driver so
he could travel between them.
Taylor had another 10
years and used them well
as an admired townsman
whose word mattered.
He served as the first
African-American on the board
of a black state college, and
he worked with a powerful white
man, as it happened-- and
this, I think, is amazing--
a leader of the
1898 massacre to try
for New Deal funding
to help local farmers
gain better status
to get a better
community for local farmers,
and recreational facilities
for the black teenagers.
Taylor wanted to return to
Liberia to continue that work,
but his health
did not permit it.
He died in the Tuskegee chapel
in 1942 while on a visit.
He had just pronounced the
building his masterpiece.
Taylor left a record of
kindness and generosity,
along with a becoming modesty
about his own achievements.
He was a lovely man to know,
his daughter-in-law told me.
She never would have
known about this MIT
degree had not others told her.
When I complained
to a grand-niece
it was hard to
find out about him,
she replied and
with some asperity,
I thought, that he was too busy
helping humanity to keep up
records about himself.
Taylor believed in work
for its own satisfaction,
and attention to detail,
financial prudence, religion
for the solace it can
bring one, keeping
one's word, and service.
Finally, when I asked his son
if Taylor thought he was more
an educator or an
architect, Edward Taylor
split the difference.
Robert R. Taylor thought
of himself as an educator,
and here the pause
was deliberate,
but he knew that he
was an architect.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you,
Ellen, for that talk.
Before I introduce
our keynote speaker,
I'd like to give you some
background and the reason
for this conference.
Two years ago, the committee was
curated under Stanford Anderson
from the Department
of Architecture
to steady the situation with
under-represented minorities.
There are many parts of that
study, and many of them,
which can be discussed, perhaps,
later on in the conference
later tomorrow.
There was one element to say
the least that was shocking.
We discovered that
we had graduated
only six African-Americans
at the M-Arch level
in the past nine years, versus
2,210 non-African-Americans.
So that's roughly
three African-Americans
for every thousand
non-African-Americans.
Meaning that MIT had
done a terrible job
recognizing the problem,
much less providing
any leadership in it.
Perhaps it was
because the department
was so international, with
people and languages from all
over the world filling
our corridors that we
didn't notice.
I don't know, but what I
do know is that the failure
to recognize this low graduation
rate was a mistake on our part,
and there's no sense
to sugarcoat it now.
The graph that I show here
is roughly the graduations
in the last 100 years.
Whereas women have risen
remarkably over the last 30
years, and constituted
here at MIT,
as in most places in the
US, 50% of the student body,
the story of
African-American students
is not so rosy, nor
even so promising.
We graduated no more
African-Americans today
than we did in the late 1950s.
In fact, given the
bump in the late 60s--
you can sort of see
there's a little bit--
it goes up in the
1960s and early 70s,
in which there are several
alumni here in the audience.
We can say that we
are doing, perhaps,
even worse than we did in
the 1960s after 50 years.
Now, I don't know if
other schools are facing
similar situations,
I do suspect so,
but that doesn't change
the message that we have
for you here today, which is
that the first step to change
is certainly to recognize
our own failures,
and this we have to
do quite publicly.
It is the first step
to rebuilding trust.
Part of the reason
for this conference
is therefore to learn how
to speak of the problem,
and it's not necessarily
an easy task.
I for one, had to learn
how to do it myself,
and it began when I talked
with David Sledge, who
is coming in from Georgia.
Stuck somewhere, I think.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: There he is.
It was [INAUDIBLE] student,
some five years ago,
something like that,
and I asked him
one day out of the
blue what it was
like to be the only black
student in the department,
and he answered that it was
the first time anyone here had
asked him that question at MIT.
I didn't really
understand the depth
of what he had meant at first,
but it began to slowly sink in.
So I thank him for
that conversation,
and for the conversations
we've had since.
I've learned from Larry
Sasse who teaches here
in the department about
issues of tokenism,
and questions of mentoring,
and how, in some sense,
the whole issue of
African-Americans
is a question of discourse.
And I learned from conversations
with Dan Hendricks, who
is also sitting somewhere here.
Up there.
With conversations
about him, and it
was these conversations that
led us to the conference itself
when we sat around,
and we said, well,
we have to do more than
just talk about it.
We have to bring
in people to have
an open and frank discussion
about teaching, administration,
and about architecture,
about the profession.
And to learn to see
the problem not just
as an African-American issue,
but as a broad cultural issue
in the field of architecture
and architectural education,
for which all of
us, white and black,
national and international,
should have a claim.
There is no magic
bullet, that is for sure.
The issue is complex
and multi-faceted.
But 10 years from now, we
will be in a better position
than we are today, that
much I guarantee you.
10 years from now, we hope
that MIT will no longer
be seen as an example
of the problem,
but as an example
of the solution.
The Chairman of the
Department of Architecture,
Yung Ho-Chang, who is somewhere
over there, Dean Adele Santos,
Provost, and Culbert, and
others at MIT's administration
have committed MIT to
understanding the problem,
and to working with
us on this issue.
So on these two notes, which
are the note of honesty
and of optimism, I would like to
introduce our keynote speaker,
Ted Landsmark.
He's known nationally
and internationally
for his commitment
to the questions
of architectural education,
and as a spokesperson
of the African-American cause.
He's the director of the
Boston Architectural College,
located just across the
river in the Back Bay
and I'm glad he didn't get swept
into the river walking over
here.
He's received fellowships from
the Museum of Early Southern
Decorative Arts, the
National Science Foundation,
he serves on an editorial board
of the magazine of Architecture
Boston.
Landsmark also serves as
a trustee to numerous arts
related foundations,
including Boston's Institute
of Contemporary Art,
and Museum of Fine Arts.
Ted, welcome to MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
LANDSMARK: Wow, this
isn't pointing this right.
How do I advance this?
Excuse me, while we
do some technology,
I've served as President of
the Association of Collegiate
Schools of Architecture over
the course of the past year,
and in that capacity,
I've had an opportunity
to get to about 70 of the
accredited architecture
programs around the country,
of which there are now
either 116 or 117, and
we'll talk that differential
towards the end of my comments.
One thing that's quite clear
is that the kinds of issues
that you're trying
to address here--
hopefully, this booming will go
away in terms of my microphone.
But the kinds of
issues that we're
being called upon
to address here
are, obviously, not
listening to MIT.
I taught here in the Department
of Urban Studies and Planning
a number of years ago,
back in the late 70s,
at a point in time when a lot of
these issues were being raised,
a lot of this talked
about it at the time.
A lot of us tried
to do something,
but the issues
have not gone away,
as I think everyone knows.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about race and architecture.
about architectural education
as a broader context for
trying to understand some
of the issues that we need
to address if we're going
to be specific about developing
some solutions for the issues
of race and
architecture, and I also
have to talk just a little
bit about the practice
of architecture, the
profession thereof.
As I think many of
you know, the VAC
is a practice-based
learning institution.
So all of our graduates have
to work three years in firms
before they can graduate,
and as a consequence,
I get to see a lot of what's
going on in firms these days.
And what's going on in
firms, to a large extent,
I think, replicates or echos
what has gone on in schools.
I should also note
that ordinarily,
when I've been called upon over
the course of the past year
to try to discuss these
issues, the conversation
is with American Institute
of Architecture groups,
or various licensing
groups such as NCARB, which
means that ordinarily, I'm
speaking to audiences that
are 98% white, and
usually about 70% male,
and ordinarily, those
groups are groups
that have to be persuaded
that some form of diversity
is a good thing.
That they need to think
about and address because,
by and large, if there is
any American profession
that has gotten
away with the kind
of benign neglect of
diversifying itself
over the course of the last
30 years, its architecture.
Law addressed these same
issues 30 years ago,
medicine addressed these
same issues, business schools
addressed these same issues.
They developed
solutions, and when
you go into those
kinds of schools,
you see a very
different student.
In fact, they make up
[INAUDIBLE] in design schools.
So change is possible, but it's
only possible in the context
of a broader cultural and
professional set of changes,
and whatever MIT
elects to do will
be very important, and
useful because MIT is clearly
viewed as a leader
within that field
of architectural education.
But you're also taking on
an entire profession which
has elected, to a
very large extent,
to ignore these
issues completely.
There are about 100,000 licensed
architects in the United States
at this moment.
That's a convenient
number because it
helps to get the
percentages very easily.
It's probably closer right
now to about 102,000.
Of that 100,000, as far as
we've been able to tell,
1571 are African-American,
and of that 100,000,
186 are African-American
women out of 100,000.
The upcoming issue of Architect
Magazine, as far as I know,
is doing a cover story.
I don't know if it's out yet.
AUDIENCE: It's out.
LANDSMARK: OK, I
haven't seen that,
but this conference was reported
in Architectural Record,
and Architect Magazine
has taken note.
The magazines took note
of this 30 years ago too,
and they didn't
do much about it.
The hope is that at this point,
these numbers will change.
The Cambridge School
of Design that I'm
referring to-- actually, I
have a more updated number.
It's not 36.
I think it's actually 48 that
that well-known Cambridge
School of Design have graduated
over the last 35 or 40 years.
That number shows up shortly.
In the entire commonwealth
of Massachusetts,
there are 29 licensed
African-American architects.
One J. Lee just came online, but
then we lost one through death
a couple of months ago.
So the numbers have not changed.
29 out of about 3,000.
This slide, I normally have to
put up for my white audiences.
Here, presumably the
fact that you're here
in the midst of a
blizzard and northeaster
means that you get it.
This jumped twice.
Diversity is important because
the market that they serve
has become diversified.
It is global, and as long as
the American Architectural
profession purports
to be in a position
to understand the cultural,
ergonomic, aesthetic values
of most of the world,
and is a profession that
remains with 1.5%
African-American participation
in that profession, we can't
really hold ourselves out
to be the kind of profession
that can really serve
the world very effectively.
The total number of architects
in the United States
has increased very slightly over
the course of the last decade
or so.
There was a slight dip,
which was brought on
in part by a recession
in the early 90s.
That doesn't show up here,
but the actual numbers
of architects in
the United States
have not changed dramatically.
Here's the why is this
important question.
This is a profession
that tends, particularly
when one focuses on the
effects of modernism
on architectural
education and the like,
to hold out that it's
possible to plant
the same kind of building
anywhere in the world.
But in fact, there
are many of us
who believe that that
does a disservice
to the clients in those
varying parts of the world.
And what we've found
is that certainly
from a marketing point
of view, and this
is what I always have to
explain to affirm principles,
being a more diverse
firm opens more
opportunities for that firm.
It creates a better kind
of and richer dialogue
within the firm, as more
people of diverse backgrounds
bring different kinds
of perspectives.
I remember when I was
at Yale, for example,
and we were asked to design
a public housing development,
some of my classmates actually
planted a baby grand piano
in the drawings
that they did, and I
as a kid who grew
up in the projects
knew that that was ridiculous,
but as of the time that I
was in school,
those students had
no idea of the
inappropriateness of that.
Plus diversity is the
right thing for us to do.
The other thing
that's interesting
is that there is more of a need
for architects in the world
today than at any
time in our history,
but the profession itself
is not growing as such.
So to a large extent, whether
it's because of the objections
that many practitioners raised,
and engineers, and developers,
and builders are taking away
all of the work of architects,
that's one issue.
But the larger issue is
that the profession itself
has not embraced what
its responsibility is
to really provide service
to all of the people
in the world who
need architects.
So in a funny, but
not so funny way,
this profession is the
only major profession
that I've found in the United
States that in proportion
to the world need, is
actually shrinking,
and it's becoming a
niche profession that
celebrates a certain
kind of architecture,
but not, in fact, the
kind of architecture
that needs to be done.
When I've done this presentation
to student groups, which again,
are primarily white, and
young, and full of enthusiasm,
and really terrific kids,
and all that sort of stuff,
the first thing I have
to point out to them
is that in 25 years,
their clients will not
look like what they
look like, and that they
need to get used to that
idea, and figure out
how to adjust to that.
It's an interesting
slide in that
it talks about the percentages.
When we look at
American professions,
where do architects
stand in relation
to other kinds of professions?
The 129,000 figure is
a somewhat soft figure.
In fact, a census data--
the most recent
census data, argue
that there are almost 200,000
people in the United States
who declare themselves
to be architects.
Only half of those are licensed.
So somewhere between
100,000 to 200,000,
there is a number of people who
are practicing this profession.
That number is not
important in of in itself.
What's important is that in
relation to other professions,
basically there are 10
accountants for every architect
in the United States.
There are five doctors
for every architect.
There are more than 10
engineers for every architect.
So we start with a small number
of individuals who are actually
practicing this profession.
And there's always
been discussion
about why it is that
African-Americans and other
people of color don't
go into this field,
and often, it's
not-- the argument
is put forward that the
smart black guy isn't
going to become an
architect because he
can't make as much money.
He's going to become
a lawyer instead,
like I became a lawyer rather
than becoming an architect.
But the reality of
the circumstance
is that in comparison
with other professions,
architects earn a living wage.
And what we've discovered
from some of the polling
that we did, some of the studies
that the American Institute
of Architects undertook two
years ago, what we discovered
is that, in fact, the
people going to architect
don't go into architecture
for the money.
None of us do that.
We go into it because
we like to make stuff.
We're builders.
We're makers of things.
We're designers of things, and
that the economic incentives
in and of themselves
are not sufficient
disincentives for people
to go into this field.
Indeed, when one looks at
the AIAs old figures in terms
of what it is that architects
earn in the United States,
one would have to argue
that, in fact, most of these
are living wages, and I know
that our BAC graduates, when
they come out of school, if
they know a little bit of Revit,
are starting in the
$50,000 to $55,000
range, which is not a
bad starting salary.
It takes you a long
time to get there,
but it's hardly a poverty wage.
And that, in fact,
principals of major firms
in this country, owners,
are earning six figures,
and some good six figures.
So the argument that's often
put forward that people of color
don't go into this
field because they
can't earn enough money in it
is pretty much a bogus argument.
And then when people
say that to me,
I also flip the argument
around and ask, well,
if people of color
are too smart to go
into this low paying field,
what's wrong with all
the white men who do?
Are they all really coming
from white shoe backgrounds?
The answer is no, they're not.
So the economic side of
all of this is bogus.
Because there's
so much text here,
I've added some slides
of some of the architects
we ought to think about.
Those people who have, in fact,
constituted the foundation
of black architecture
in this country.
So we know that there
are 100,000 architects,
and we're going to get into some
more detail here around that.
Hopefully it will be discussed
in further detail tomorrow.
There are about 33,000 folks
in our architecture schools,
and we'll get to that
number in a moment.
But of the 200,000 people
who declared themselves
to be architects,
roughly 20% are
women, a little bit less than 3%
are African-American, nearly 6%
are either Hispanic or Latino.
It's hard to count Hispanics
and Latinos because
of self-declaration issues.
Roughly 6% are Asian, 3% say
that they are American Indian.
So technically,
as among those who
declare themselves to
be architects, about 15%
are so-called people of color.
In NCARB, the licensing
body at this point,
reports about 101,000
licensed architects.
Part of the difficulty that
we have in this profession
is that there's no central
database from which one
can draw information that tells
you what the real number is
because, in fact, NCARB,
the national licensing body,
draws its information by calling
around to all of the state
licensing bodies, and since
many architects are registered
in more than one
state, there isn't
a way at this moment
of getting one
definitive number on the total
number of licensed architects.
But of the 80,000 members
of the American Institute
of Architects,
interestingly, only 12%
are women, despite the fact that
for at least 10, 12, 15 years,
half of the students in all
of our architecture programs
in the country have been women.
Only 12% of the members
of the American Institute
of Architects are women,
2% are Hispanic or Latino,
1.5% are black, 3% are Asian.
We also did some surveys
a couple of years ago,
now, of people who
are practicing,
but not members of the American
Institute of Architects.
And interestingly, of those
numbers, about 10% are women.
Well, you can see the
numbers for yourself.
Architecture school graduates
are interesting as well.
The total number of architecture
school students in the country
has varied minimally
in the last 20 years.
It's varied from
about a low of 31,000
to a high of about
33,000, 34,000.
The actual number of
graduates in any given year
is about 3,000 from all of
our programs across the United
States.
And in comparison with who is
in higher education overall,
and I have several layers
of data here, more than half
of all of the students enrolled
in higher ed in the United
States are now women.
A little bit less than 10%
are African-American, about 6%
Latino, about 6% Asian.
In Masters programs,
interestingly, nearly 60%
are women, about 7% to
8% are African-American,
a little over 4% are
Hispanic, almost 5% are Asian.
And there's among those
getting master's degrees
in this country, only about
2% of all master's degrees
that are awarded in the country
are awarded in architecture.
The vast majority are in
business, engineering, law,
health care.
This does not count
education fields,
where there are huge
numbers of individuals,
and EEDs, and PhDs.
But as among traditionally
defined professional degrees,
architecture amounts to only
2% of all of the degrees
that are awarded
in any given year.
So of our 33,000, almost
34,000 architecture students,
a little bit less than a third
would be considered minority,
and as you break it down in
terms of levels of programs--
and these numbers start to
get particularly interesting
for us.
In pre-professional
degrees, there
were only 116
African-American graduates
of pre-professional
degrees in 2003,
which was the most recent
year we had data on this.
In our B-Arch programs,
there were only 116 graduates
from B-Arch programs
nationally in 2003.
In our master's programs,
there were only 40 graduates
of M-Arch programs in 2003
who were African-American.
And now we get to the
really hard stuff,
which is to say where are those
African-Americans coming from?
And it turns out
that 37%, according
to data that's been developed
by Dennis Mann and Brad Grant
through the University
of Cincinnati,
37% of all
African-American architects
hold at least one degree from
an historically black college
or university.
That means that of
the 117 programs
that are now accredited
in the country,
the seven HBCUs are
turning out 37%.
Or roughly 5% of all of
the programs in the country
are turning out nearly 40% of
the African-American graduates.
So what are those schools?
And again, this is from--
this was actually updated
just about six months ago.
Howard has turned out the
largest number, followed
by Hampton, Tuskegee, Southern
down in Baton Rouge, Florida
A&M, which is not an accredited
program, Prairie View in Texas,
Tennessee State, which is
not an accredited program,
and Oregon State.
It's also interesting to
see when these programs were
accredited in relation to how
many graduates have come out
of them.
And then what about
the rest of us?
What about the so-called
majority schools?
And here,
increasingly, I've only
listed the schools
that can say that they
have 20 or more licensed
African-American graduates.
Columbia's at the top, CCNY,
Urbana, Harvard, that's
the 48 number that
we've come upon,
Berkeley, Cornell, Michigan,
MIT reports a total
of 30, Tech, Detroit Mercy,
NYIT, my Alma mater, Yale,
and IIT.
There are some
interesting patterns here
in terms of urban-rural,
east coast, central, Chicago,
Berkeley.
None of us have done
well is the bottom line.
Back in 1968 with the young
then head of the National
Urban League made a speech
to the American Institute
of Architects
national convention.
He chastised the profession
because in 1968, only 1%
of all the licensed architects
in the United States
were African-American.
Today, we've gotten
it up to 1.5%.
We are almost certainly the
worst profession in the United
States for having made
any kind of change
over the last 40 years.
And I hate making reference
to this particular image,
but it's true.
If we were to triple the
number of African-Americans who
graduated from our programs
over the next decade,
we'd still only
be up around 10%.
And the fact of the matter
is most of our programs
aren't anywhere
close to tripling
the numbers of our graduates.
So the fact of the matter is
that there is every probability
that unless we
take radical steps,
someone else, 15 years from now,
will stand on this platform,
and will be able to use
exactly the same slides
with minor updates.
One of the issues
that always comes up
is around what happens
after folks graduate.
How long does it take to get
through the architectural
registration exam?
And to what extent
is there an impact--
a differential impact-- on
people of color in terms
of getting to licensure
once they've graduate?
And the reality
is that we didn't
find a substantial difference,
although what we did find
is that in significant numbers,
which presumably will be talked
about tomorrow,
there is a higher
probability that a
graduate of an HBCU
will opt not to go through
the abuse of going to work
for a firm in the areas
where most of the HBCUs
are located for a
three-year internship
to then take a licensing
exam, when they can go
to work for HUD, or
the Defense Department,
or the Corps of Engineers.
Doing architectural work at
a higher starting salary,
never have to get
a license, have
a lifetime of job
security, and never go
into traditional
private practice.
And indeed, that appears to
account to a very large extent
for what happens to graduates of
African-American HBCU programs.
That is they choose the path
that is the most logical path,
and they opt not to go
into private practice.
And the whole
question of internship
raises one other
very difficult issue
within the context of the
profession as we move forward.
I don't know if any of
you were participants
in the American Institute
of Architects Students
Annual Convention, which
occurred this year here
in Boston over at the Sheraton.
About 1100 students came in,
and the BAC, and Wentworth
co-hosted those students.
And one of the
presentations there
was from a firm in India,
an outsourcing firm.
The kind of firm that our
architecture firms don't
like to talk about a lot
because of all the liability
issues that are inherent in
sending your work to India
overnight to have your
production drawings done.
And until very recently,
the whole business
of outsourcing
within the profession
was simply something that
no one talked about at all.
But all those friends are
now out of the closet,
and we managed to
get a presentation
from one of those firms at
the AIA meeting in Boston.
And the firm
principal said, look,
I have the ability to employ
1,000 people in my firm
in India, or in similar firms
in Pakistan, or China, or Egypt.
You do your work
here during the day,
and send your work to me
electronically overnight.
My 1,000 people will
turn around your work
more efficiently than can
an intern in your office
because they're
well-versed in Revit.
They know all of
the latest software,
and they're doing this
kind of work for firms
all over the world.
We can get the word back to
you the next morning at 1/5
the cost.
And so students who
are at this conference,
at the end of the presentation,
went up to some of the people
from NCARB and said
well, wait a minute,
if the work that we as interns
used to be able to do in order
to develop the skill sets
necessary to take an exam
can now be done in India at
1/5 the cost, what kind of work
are we as interns going to
be doing if you hire us?
And none of the folks
from NCARB had an answer
to that because it is
becoming increasingly
clear that the kind of work
that architecture school
graduates have
been doing in firms
is now being outsourced
for much less money
and more proficiently.
We asked a series of questions
through the AIA as to what
were the key reasons for
people not practicing,
and we did some comparative
analysis of these.
I can't go into all
the detail here.
For those of you who
want to see that detail,
we've posted it on
the BAC website.
It was commissioned work
that was done for the AIA,
and then the AIA didn't
want to release the study.
But since I chaired the
diversity committee,
and worked with the
firm that did the study,
I thought I had some
proprietary right
to hang onto the
results of the study.
So for any of you
who really want
to see the full 120-page study,
you can go to our website,
and it's quietly posted there.
But what it does
indicate is that many
of the reasons for
folks not practicing
in terms of differentials--
basically, race and gender,
have nothing to do with
inability to do the work,
unwillingness to do the work,
or even the usual bugaboo that's
mentioned for women, families.
That in fact, most of the
people who graduated from school
have every intention of
practicing in some way, shape,
or form, and that the
usual stuff of gee,
I can't find enough
people because they
don't want to be this
kind of work is a life.
What are the normal
institutional impediments
that we have come upon through
our studies in terms of entry
into the profession?
I might as well use the word.
Someone else will at
some point, if I don't.
Racism is out there.
It's alive and well
in the profession.
There's a lot of great
talk about yes, we're open,
and yes, we want
to hire everyone,
but racism is evident
in many of the firms.
The patronage and class system
for obtaining private work
drives a lot of what
determines who goes into work,
and who can survive
in this field
because we all know
the clients are--
private clients,
in particular, are
individuals who one meets
through social networks,
and the like, and if you're not
a part of that social network,
you tend not to see them.
I go to many, many, many
events in the greater Boston
area put on by my
friends and colleagues
in the architectural
profession, and invariably, I
am the only person of
color there, even today.
Lack of role models,
lack of access to capital
markets in order to get the
work done, and interestingly,
and this came out
of a study that
was done as much in Australia,
where some polling was done
a number of years ago around
racial and gender differences
in terms of coming
into the profession,
it turns out that significant
proportions of women and people
of color who decide
to go into this field
have an orientation
towards doing
work that would be considered
community based work.
It's not the kind of work
that's celebrated, by and large,
in our major publications,
or even in our schools,
or in our awards patterns.
We celebrate the high profile
individual corporate work,
or the individual home.
We tend not to
celebrate the work
of the great community based
architect designs of YMCA.
And as a result,
what tends to happen
within the context of studio
culture and other culture
is that we celebrate exactly
the kind of work, which is not
the kind of work that most
women and people of color
come into this field to do.
And so there's not
much of an incentive as
among students who
are studying this
to feel as though the kind of
work that we might want to do
is the kind of work that's
likely to be celebrated.
Let me also note, again,
in the context of the wider
profession, what the key
issues are that deans--
and these are American deans--
view as the key issues
that are coming up
in terms of both
education, and what's
happening in practice
at this moment,
and these are
interesting issues.
Interdisciplinary
design, effective design,
and communication.
Finally, there's a recognition
that many, many architects
are wonderful
designers, but totally
unable to express
themselves in any form other
than graphically.
They can't write, they can't
speak, they can't present,
and architecture
firms are increasingly
saying we'd like to
have some people here
who know how to present their
work as well as producing it.
Sustainability, of course,
technological growth,
human health and safety,
and issues around licensure.
And let me just say that the
licensure issue was viewed
as somewhat abstract
for me until last week
when I found out that the
Canadian equivalent of NCARB,
our American licensing
group, has just collapsed.
The four major provinces
that represent about 3/4
of all of the
architects in Canada
have decided to
withdraw their support
from the Canadian
equivalent of NCARB,
and in doing that, they've
decided that they are now
going to write their
own provisional exams.
And I've shared that
information when
I got it with the NCARB folks
just two or three days ago
in Philadelphia, and
they haven't heard
it yet, but clearly, that's
going to have some ripples
and repercussions for things
like international reciprocity
of licensure, and the ability
to work across national borders
generally, and the fact
that certain American states
like California and Texas have
been moving in that direction
anyway.
So the question is what are
we educating our students
for if we're
thinking that they're
going to become
licensed at some point,
if the very structure
of licensure
seems to be collapsing?
And that's something that
remains to be answered.
BIM, that is Building
Information Modeling
for those of you who
aren't in the middle of it,
and performance based software
integration, the whole set
of issues that comes up around
embedded intelligence in design
software.
Suburban and urban growth,
increasing globalization,
design build processes,
project delivery.
Talent shortages we'll
come to in just a moment,
but I have to say that having
visited nearly 70 programs
in the United States,
most of our schools
are not talking
about BIM at all.
We do talk about growth issues.
We do talk about globalization,
but one is hard pressed
to go to an architecture
school that's talking
about design build processes.
They're out there,
but few in number.
And I've raised one
other issue, and that
is to say that as
of next fall, there
will be a major conference.
This occurs every five or
six years, during which
the very structure of
architectural education
is going to be reassessed,
and perhaps, revised.
And as we've started talking
about all of this stuff,
I remind folks that
the last time we
had one of these
conversations, which
was only four or five
years ago, things like BIM,
and integrated practice,
and Revit, and outsourcing,
and work sharing were
not discussed at all.
And yet we came up with
a set of guidelines
for what architectural
accreditation should
be without reference
to any of these things.
So whatever we talk
about next year, which
will set the standards for what
architectural education will
be until 2015 is
almost certain to be
a discussion about a number
of things, which none of us
have begun to think
about in terms
of what design
education will be,
and how that will also be
affected by cultural, racial,
and gender factors.
I always like to ask what are
the skills that we really bring
to the architectural process?
What is the value added that any
architect brings to a client?
How does one change a slide
if it doesn't want to change?
And that is,
ultimately, knowledge
of clients, and the
ability to listen,
which is not something we
generally teach in school,
needs and interpretation for
our clients, which some of us
teach, problem analysis,
and problem solving,
the ability to innovate,
which MIT has always
been spectacularly good at.
I always loved teaching here.
Anytime I worked
out into a Carter,
I felt as though between
the students and faculty,
we were on the cutting edge
of knowledge in the universe,
and I know that that continues.
So that's not an issue here.
And project management.
And I have to go
through this list
because as we talk
about globalization,
and its impact on education
generally, there is a poll,
and I think they
finally wrapped it up,
that was done by the
European equivalent
of the Association of American
Schools of Architecture.
And what they asked was, what
is it that firms in Europe
are looking for in
design school graduates?
And it turns out
that what they found
is very similar to
what the American
Institute of Architects has
also found in its own polling.
Number 10 on the
list is the ability
to develop trans-disciplinary
understanding.
Nine is the ability to learn.
Eight is the ability
to evaluate evidence.
Seven on the list
is design skill.
Six is the ability
to apply knowledge
that one has obtained
in school to practice.
Five is the ability
to create designs
that satisfy ascetic and
technical requirements.
Four is the ability to work with
a high degree of both autonomy
and collaboratively.
Three is the ability to work
in interdisciplinary teams.
Two, interestingly, are the
personal and social skills
in expression that enable one
to interact with a client.
And number one has nothing to do
with design as we traditionally
understand it.
Number one is the ability
to have critical thinking
and analytical skill.
Sorry to skip over
Robert Taylor,
but you heard about him.
We also need to
think about what it
is that comes out of our
schools because there's a panel
tomorrow that will be
talking about education,
and how we go about assessing
quality in the schools.
Obviously, great
faculty and resources,
innovative academic depth.
Again, not an issue here.
Design within rigorous
curriculum, not an issue here.
Excellent students,
not an issue here.
But there are a
bunch of things that
throughout this
contextualizing of what
it is we're training for,
there are a bunch of things
that we have to ask why
is it that people of color
have been excluded from
all of this learning?
What's going on?
What is the problem here?
And we've listed some
of the impediments,
and we also know that there
have been many initiatives that
have been put in place over
the course of the last 30, 40
years.
Ford Foundation invested
millions of dollars
in conjunction with
the American Institute
of Architects, starting
in the late 60s
and into the early 70s, in
supporting scholarships.
I can look around this room.
I will do this because I
have to do this periodically.
Are there any people
in this room who
know anyone who got
one of those Ford AIA
grads who became an architect?
No.
The point is that millions
have been invested
in efforts and initiatives
that no one bothered
to track the effectiveness of.
So we did a lot of
feel good things,
and those feel good things
got us from 1% to 1.5%,
and that clearly hasn't
been good enough.
So the recommendations
that have been put forward
to try to change
all of this, include
increasing public awareness
of what architecture is.
I mean, let's face it, most
people have no idea what we do.
Ensuring adequate
resources, that usually
means scholarships, but it also
means other kinds of resources.
Increasing the visibility of
architects of color, hence
the images I've included here.
And expanding the nature
and diversity of leaders
within the profession,
growing people,
and putting them out
front so that more people
know about the work of Mel
Mitchell or Robert Colts.
Improving licensure rates and
developing mentoring programs.
And part of what we
realized is that there
are not-- if there are only
1571 African-American architects
in the United States, they
can't all be mentors as such.
So it means we've got five
different kinds of mentors
to step out.
I am not, for example,
a licensed architect,
and yet I've won the AIAs
Whitney Young award for my work
in this field because I
believe in architecture.
There are many other
people like myself
who believe in architecture who
are not licensed architects,
who are prepared to try to
work to change the numbers.
We have to be called
upon, but the profession
tends to have so much hubris
and insularity that it tends
not to look to us very
often for what it is we're
prepared to try to contribute.
Requiring diversity
training within our firms,
certainly, but
ordinarily, we try
to start with our
local AIA components,
where people just
sort of take it
for granted that they're
so smart, and capable,
and tolerant, and outgoing
that, in fact, they
don't need to understand
what it is they're
doing in their firms.
Like the firm principal who
came to me once, and made
a suggestion as to
what color of colleague
he would like me
to-- like to see
me showing up at
social events with as
recently as four months ago.
People just don't get it.
And then finally, a set of
more specific recommendations
that we're working to
develop that hopefully,
people will talk about
here and elsewhere.
One of the things we realize
is that by and large,
the folks who go
into this field have
been exposed to it
fairly early on,
without regard to
race or gender.
Someone in the family was
involved in construction,
or had a hardware store, or
took him to Home Depot a lot
to do minor repairs
around the house.
It's something people
are familiar with,
and we need to start earlier
than high school to begin
to introduce folks to things.
Corporate involvement of
design supply companies.
It struck me that
in many respects,
the easiest way to
do outreach would
be to serve a card table
out in front of a Home
Depot, or a Lowes in
a community of color,
and have your schools sit
there, and say this is
what it is to be an architect.
We want you to think
about coming into this.
Recruiting design
school faculty of color
from fields other than from
the 1571 licensed architects.
They can't maintain
practices at the same time
that they're in a
classroom teaching.
You're asking us to do too much.
Giving voice to students
of color in design schools.
I see one of my recent
graduates here, Brandi Brooks,
who now runs the Community
Design Center of Boston.
And when she was in
school, we saw to it
that people knew who she
was, and all of our schools
have to do that.
Promoting a broad diversity of
opinions within private design
firms, which doesn't
happen a lot these days.
Monitor the government and
foundation diversity programs
that exist at this
moment to raise
the question of
whether they're just
feel good efforts, or something
that really has an effect,
and acknowledge and support
the cultural globalization
of design practice.
And that means recognizing that
while our schools and our firms
are not necessarily up to speed
with the diversity of design,
the reality is practice is.
And finally, there is
a major effort that's
being made at this moment.
Finally, it's among the
architects organizations--
to do what has happened
in law and medicine
for the last 30
years, and that is
to develop systematic data
tracking so that one knows
who's enrolled in our schools,
what programs they're in,
who graduates, who goes
into IDP, who takes the ARE,
who becomes licensed,
where at this moment,
again, there's no
centralized data source that
enables us to know all of that.
And literally, within
the last few weeks,
the collateral
organizations that
oversee architecture and
architectural education
have finally begun to
ask those questions,
and to develop a unified
data tracking system.
And there are a
bunch of questions
that we hope that this data
tracking system will finally
help us to answer.
So thanks.
Yeah, I'm into the
global economy too.
And I didn't get to
print all of these out,
but I'll see to it
that we get these.
Until about five
or eight years ago,
there were not a lot of
useful sources of information
on any of this, but the numbers
have grown fairly significantly
in the last couple of
years, and since we're
in an academic environment,
here are some good references
for you, including Mel's
book and a couple of others
done by folks who are here.
So I'll say one
last thing, which
is in most respects,
the hardest thing
to say because you're not
supposed to know this.
37% of our African-American
architects come from HBCUs.
For the first time ever,
our accrediting agency
has had to make the
difficult choice
to discredit one of our
117 programs because
of the weak performance
of that school.
I know because of my position
that that school has received
a letter, and that the
faculty at that school
are now meeting with
their administrators
to try to figure out what
should happen because there are
only seven of those schools.
So I can't tell you
who the school is
because it's not appropriate.
I will say that to the extent
that any one of our HBCUs
fails that we have a
major problem in terms
of increasing diversity
within the profession.
And what is, for me,
most poignant and ironic
is that that school that
has lost its accreditation
is one of the schools that
Robert Taylor had the most
contact with.
Now, all of us, as
was the case at Tulane
in New Orleans and the Gulf
region, all of us at schools
figured out how to come
together after Katrina
to provide support for
faculty and students
who ran the risk of having their
academic careers fundamentally
disrupted in the
post-Katrina era,
and as a result of things
that all of our schools did,
students who were at Tulane and
at other schools in that area,
were able to complete
their studies
and graduate because the rest
of us came together to help out.
I would submit to you that over
the course of the next day,
as you have your
conversations, one
of the things you
need to think about
is how we here in this room,
and in other schools that
are doing well will
have to come together
literally over the course of
the next two to three months
to provide some aid and
support for one of our schools
where because of the
lack of accreditation,
students who
graduated last year,
and students who are
graduating this year
will not be eligible to take
a licensing exam because they
will have graduated from a
non-NAV accredited school.
So if we're going to talk
about doing anything,
let us talk about
the help that we
need to provide to those
schools and students who
are most in need.
And with that, you
have an overview,
and let's have a
great conference.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
third from the bottom.
Good or bad, you just named--
I don't know if it was
inadvertant or not,
but you did name the school.
LANDSMARK: I made
a reference to it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you named it.
Now, and I hope
this is something
we're going to get a chance
to talk about tomorrow
because the fundamental issues
as to why that school failed
isn't anything anybody
at MIT did or didn't do.
It goes to the heart of some
issues that we in our circles
have to really,
really talk about.
Whether this is the proper
venue or not, I don't know,
but you get my drift here?
LANDSMARK: Well, yeah.
What we try to do when we
find out these kinds of things
is to make sure that there
are appropriate offline
venues for these
conversations, and I
would anticipate that over the
course of the next day or so,
there will be a number of
appropriate offline venues
where this can be discussed.
AUDIENCE: Got you.
DAVIS: I know the focus
is an academic focus here,
but in my experience
and practice is such
that so much of the work
is in our profession is
tied to a tradition that's
a gentleman's practice.
So many of my colleagues
have learned--
I learned about architecture
because my mother
used to drive us around
as kids to look at houses,
and that's how--
but it was not because
of anything deliberate
in the culture
that supported me.
The person who built our
house was a black architect
and builder not registered
in the state of Florida,
but he build because he grew
up in a segregated community,
and he had a clientele.
Today, and as I was
growing up, most
of the architects that
I knew were successful
developed that success through
a clientele that was government,
community based, some churches.
Most of the architects that
I know who got their starts,
got their starts in
the social fabric.
I feel very strongly that
the schools have a role,
but that role is
very, very limited
in the sense that from a
practice point of view,
the ability for us to begin to
strengthen the social fabric,
and let's talk about
that more aggressively,
and how we begin to get
people to think about
in our communities, being
more aggressive about doing
that is where it's at.
I don't think the
problem of race
are going to be solved
because white people decided
to do the right thing.
I think it's going to be solved
because white people understand
that this culture will
not sustain itself
without functioning in a
way that embraces all of us.
And it's not going to be
solved because black people put
pressure on white people.
It's going to solved
because black people begin
to think more aggressively
and creatively about how
to provide a social structure
to build our own communities.
LANDSMARK: It would
be helpful in that
regard if you said who you are
and what your current work is.
DAVIS: My name's Curtis Davis.
I'm a [INAUDIBLE]
architect, but I've
made a choice to be an
architect from the client side,
and I work with the
Smithsonian Institution.
LANDSMARK: Odd.
[CHUCKLES]
DAVIS: Why you going
to play me like that?
[LAUGHTER]
The National Museum for
African-American History
and Culture.
LANDSMARK: Thank you.
DAVIS: But the point
that I'm trying
to make about this
question of building,
who builds, how we build
is what informs the school.
I don't think that schools
inform the process.
The schools ought
to be reflections
of what the community
demands, and needs,
and that's where the support
will come to the schools.
And if the schools have a
role today in this transition,
it's to raise that question,
and bring that debate
to the table in a real,
meaningful, and aggressive way.
LANDSMARK: One thing
I'll say about that
is that it's been
interesting to me
that more of that
consciousness has emerged
from the students
themselves than from most
of our faculties.